because she worked in restaurants new oh
yeah oh yeah so you worked in Hawaii but
then he worked in LA as well yes I
worked in a restaurant in Beverly Hills
to pause it was who tried to be it was a
it look it was a terrible restaurant and
it was it was just awful and I was a
major contributing factor it was it was
just real garbage it's been revamped now
but I loved it it was the name give you
free meals I mean they will give me and
that's how I ate I mean when you're when
you're in Hollywood or in other places
like you need a job that gives you four
days free so you can try to audition for
projects so I'd worked the weekends and
I'd worked the nights and that would
that's the whole idea had no money and
no one was coming to the restaurant so I
wasn't making any tip I'd make like 20
or 30 bucks a day maybe and so it was
really a place I'd go to nourishment to
eat yeah yeah that kitchen fed me for
like the time that I was there Isis oh
man do you ever do this where you I
would like a lady would come in and
she'd be like what do you recommend I'm
like 32 ounce porterhouse
tell them I said listen here's how you
want medium-rare was and mushrooms on
the side ninety year old woman and so I
bring the steak out to this lady she I'm
not mom I'm not hiding in the corner
watching like it she like how much is
she eating and how much do I get
you know if she was like I can't eat
another bite
yes mistake is left we have a thing
called the tunnel which is an area
between the dining room in the kitchen
where they keep all the soft drinks and
like the silverware and stuff and that's
I've been busted so many times eating
off people's plates that they were like
you have to stop doing that like it's
really really bad you know so anything I
ate I had to eat in the tunnel my safe
zone the customers are gonna see me eat
their food and the chef's not gonna yell
at me for eating the food so I was like
I had about 14 maybe ounces of steak
that I had to get down in about ten feet
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the three days where the protein
right
walk back out and the lady was like
listen I'd love to get that steak to go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ma'am let me go I'll go check and I was
like Oh what do i do what do I do and I
said I'm so I'm so sorry I already threw
in the trash I threw in the trash and
she said it's for my dog it's fine just
fish it if you don't mind just fish it
out put it in a boxes I was like we'll
do like it's on the fly man don't ask
any questions just give me one right now
and so he started cooking at stake and I
was like that was a [ __ ] I went out
to where I was like ma'am I'm gonna get
you that steak they just took the
garbage out to the dumpster I'm gonna
roll up my sleeves I'm gonna jump in
that dumpster I'm gonna get it for you
because I'm what kind of dog Pomeranian
no way I love that so this week that
steak and she ended up being so like
happy that I would be willing to dig
through the garbage for her dog that she
gave me a giant tip and she left early
cuz she couldn't wait for the steak to
be done so I got another snake and like
well they're gonna prison so we know
it's researching a film and we had to go
in and basically see what the inside of
a prison look like and speak with
prisoners who are willing to talk to us
and um and it walked in and I remember
thinking and I had bunny tail long
blonde hair and I had a hat on and the
wardens knows where this is going
so expect the night and the warden said
you can't wear your hat and so on and I
said I got no worries [ __ ] they're gonna
Know Who I am than Athan and then I get
Thor in here they're not gonna watch
movies and I'd never been to prison so
assume that and the moment I started
walking through the cells and it's like
each block of this thing and it's all
just kind of the you know cell upon cell
and so on and I just start getting
heckled and it's like your doors here
man Thor's hammer man like blend in and
yo research and just getting heckled
left and right about you know come spend
some time in my shell baby you'll do
hey guys that was uh it wasn't a whole
research more just kind of it is
traditional at this point in the show
when John Bishop is on the couch to turn
to the Americans say understanding
anything he said he was in the
Fellowship of the Ring talking talking
about sense this is a weird thing so
Chris Pratt is this this seems so
unlikely that you have now learned to
how to do the voices from town yeah sort
of yeah we love that garbage TV crazy
about it and when when I was here
filming guardians we shot guardians the
galaxy here in London and and my wife on
a came out to visit and she fell in love
with this show TOWIE The Only Way Is
Essex it's this show that's like
basically their jersey shorts the Jersey
Shore from from here it's like this town
somewhere is
it's like I'm a parrot a little bit and
so when I hear when I hear it all the
time I just started picking it up and
started like I could pick up their
accent and do their accent a little bit
nah I'm okay
it's gonna sound really embarrassing to
do in front of a whole room full of
Brits here but I'll try it anyways so
it's like mmm so I want to say like a
silly scar michaelmi wings and a beef
Artemis I you know I miss you
[Applause]
we'll never be useful very useful very
good do the accent you bet the costumes
right to look right you're in those
grueling you know conditions in Scotland
filming for months and then you premiere
the film in Toronto and that's not what
got attention oh dear what happened yeah
what happened well I have sorry there's
a scene in the film where I am I bear
the and yeah that seemed well yeah Full
Monty the front or the back you know if
you don't like one you can talk the
other
it's all in here it's all different
strokes for different folks in festival
you know and these are the tweets to the
tweets warnings members Chris mind full
frontal outlaw King that's pretty much
where a review this is a PSA that out
looking for the booty
I mean appetizer of the frames featuring
is soaking wet full frontal nudity
thankfully Netflix has a pause
even better one that I think is vanity
snare it's like oh yeah they're they're
effin brutal yeah wait there's one
there's one more near day one observed
it down until I've been seriously
impressed by the performances of
newcomers like Chris Pines pubes and
Chris Pines Phoenix a lot of intelligent
people in the world we must Chris very
quickly mentioned Thor mostly so we can
show this picture sure won't you be
embarrassed but also apparently is this
true the people this is odd so people
come up to you and they want you to tell
a specific joke well they'll just come
and tell me for a joke like yeah go you
know the joke about the Thor spends a
night with this woman and the next
morning he says I have to tell you who I
am you know I'm Thor she says you're
four I can hardly walk
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]